he is none other than Peter King Andrew
Luck the Colts and the retirement that
rocked NFL's world is the title of his
football morning in America that came
out just this very morning back here on
the Rich Eisen show Peter King how are
you Peter everything's good rich how
about you I'm doing fine in the Honda
insider report and here on the Rich
Eisen show kind enough to to hit us up
right here let's get to it where does
this rank for you in terms of all the
stories you've covered in the NFL Peter
oh I mean it's a I think the way I would
word this is I just don't remember
anything that surprised me more I just
I've tried to think about it
because obviously people are going to
ask this question but I just don't think
anything has surprised me anymore than
this and having said all that I also
don't think that that it is altogether
unbelievable what he did because of the
kind of person that Andrew Luck is and
really I mean I wrote about it today if
you look at all of the people who you
know and you know that who you know rich
personally because obviously you know
Andrew Luck if you look at all the
people you have known covering this game
this would be the one of the guys who
would least surprise you if he walked
away from football because it's a guy
who majored in architecture at Stanford
it's a guy who had his own book club
it's a guy who every time I talk to him
I mean every time there wasn't a single
time that I talked to him that we didn't
have a conversation about some book that
one of the other one or the other of us
had read or loved so you're asking me
how surprises is I was absolutely
shocked obviously but you know now given
it a little time to have this breeze if
you ask me of the 1700 players in
football right now who
surprise me if he walked away as great
as he is long before his time Andrew
Luck would be near the top of the list
of the players so it wouldn't surprise
me that they would have walked away
well you spoke to him on August 4th
that's the way you begin your column
today where you didn't sense at all
visiting training camp from him that he
was pondering anything like this and
then 15 days later he's toast he's done
based on your reporting how did this all
come about I think the week after he
spoke to me and I was told this absence
that you know in my reporting this
weekend I was told that the week after I
was in camp he continued to have
significant pain and maybe even more
pain than he had had before this they
did a further examination and that is
when eight days after I spoke to him
Jimmy Irsay goes on a talk show and says
now the damage is more significant than
we thought Chris Ballard the next day
comes out and has a conference call with
reporters and says yes the high ankle
areas involved and yes there has been
also a ligament impingement in other
words this was not a simple cat bruise
that they sought the day that I was in
camp and I can just tell you this right
now rich you know that day I had
conversations with both Chris Ballard
and Frank Reich and also Andrew Luck
there was zero concern about this injury
Frank Reich called it child's play when
I said you got to be a little concerned
about your starting quarterback not
practicing any I wouldn't say he's
scoffed but he said Peter compared to
what I what I went through when I first
took this job last year and managing
Andrew Luck's situation this is absolute
child's play that's what he called it so
I do understand that there's a lot of
people out there saying well this just
didn't happen this has been this has
been cooking
a long time I can't I have no reporting
to back that up now I I will I will I
will make this point that when Andrew
Luck says to two reporters on Saturday
night I was determined after 2016 never
ever ever to have a season like that
again never to be in pain all the time
at practice and in games well you know
honestly I've heard him say things like
that that I'm not going through what I
did in 16 I've never heard him say that
if that happens again I'm gonna quit I
did I never heard that
and so therefore honestly rich the one
thing that Chris Ballard and Frank
Wright really tried to make Andrew Luck
think about and think seriously about is
going on that the IR with the
designation to return list you know
where after eight weeks of the season
every team can bring to two players back
that they put on IR and they tried to
get luck to do that and look was
insistent he told them and I quote I've
made up my mind a week ago today so at
that point right I think you know and
I'm reading into Frank right I'm reading
tea leaves a little bit but I think
Reich went at that point from thinking
okay I'm going to try everything I can
to convince him to settle down and this
injury he'll calm down and he'll be okay
from that point on I think he felt like
I'm just gonna try to support him and
try to get him into the next phase of
his life Peter King here on the Rich
Eisen show in the Honda inside a report
and now let's talk about what happens
from here I'm I'm not near nearly as
down on bruschettas some other people
might be I think that with this coaching
staff and how smart they are and you
want to talk about resiliency Frank
Reich is all about that I mean the man
coordinated a championship
with Nick Foles so he's all about the
backup to me that this is just a
narrative that maybe has is waiting to
blossom Peter what do you think I spent
some time last night and early this
morning watching two of his games from
2017 one early in the season a one late
and if you watch to Kobe Elsberry three
weeks into the then India what was then
the Indianapolis Colts playbook remember
rich Jacoby Elsbury wasn't rated from
the Patriots to the cold you mean
percent later right weekend Peter yeah
you've said Ellsbury I know you got the
Red Sox yeah yeah I think the Yankees
could use maybe a little bit of Ellsbury
for the first time in a few years but
yeah but anyway so so a you know I
watched two of these percent games and
the one thing look after after watching
him when he had been into the PlayBook
for only three weeks in 2017
watch him against the Cleveland Browns
and watch his presence on the field
these confidence and how he played I can
tell why Frank Wright is is like a chess
is like the Cheshire Cat right now and
and I can I could tell talking to him
this weekend that he thinks the players
are going to have a little something
tool when they report it to work today
meaning that the players are thinking
okay the outside world has given us up
for dead that's fine well show them and
you know there's nothing wrong with that
and I think even Andrew Luck would
chuckle at that that you know Vegas
going from nine wins to six wins or
whatever it is on the Colts you know on
the Colts future bet for this year I
would if I were to call typey taking
that and running with it a few minutes
left with Peter King on the Rich Eisen
show one of the Texans do now that Lamar
Miller is out for the season do they
just sit here
and figure out from within look I think
rich I think I think the the best thing
the Texans can do is try somehow someway
to get Trent Williams from Washington
I just don't the way the game is played
these days I just firmly believe you can
find a running back and are they upset
about Lamar Miller I'm sure they are but
I wouldn't trade anything of great value
I certainly wouldn't trade to Davian
clowny and then have to pay mill you
know a huge deal to get Melvin Gordon to
play I've seen that in a few places I
just think it would be a huge mistake
for them look
the Kansas City Chiefs lost Kareem hunt
last year in November and replaced him
with Damien Williams and did not miss a
beat no one ever heard of Damien
Williams that's why I just I think
running back is one of those positions
if you know the offense and you're
pretty good I don't think there's going
to be a huge huge loss for the Houston
offense is the so and then I guess maybe
this might be related with the offensive
line in DC why did Jay Gruden choose
Case Keenum to start week one against
Philadelphia and then the Giants it's
the safest thing for him now rich
because obviously Dewayne Haskins has
not appeared to be totally ready for the
rigors of an NFL game right now other
than a preseason game he has not had a
great preseason there's no reason to
rush him in and I think if you are Jay
Gruden you say without being cliche who
gives us the best chance to beat
Philadelphia on the first weekend of the
NFL season and I think right now without
any question in my mind it's Case Keenum
well you know I I always just thought
that you draft him you got to play him
but we had Ryan day of Ohio State on
Friday and he said that he and Urban
Meyer were wondering if Dwayne Haskins
was even ready to start the season for
Ohio State last year
obviously ya was but just his his uh his
greenness his lack of experience the
other thing is rich you have to think
about this what's the goal here you know
I'm reminded as much as I really really
liked Bobby better I'll never forget in
rookie training camp when Ryan leaves in
1998 was not doing well and he appeared
to be an incendiary device and all that
Bobby Besser said well you know we got a
plane we paid them all this money the
fans are excited about them we don't
have a great backup situation we were
playing this kid and I thought that as
much as I like and respect Bobby better
that that my feeling is you have to be
all about what is best for the long-term
for Dwayne Haskins if he is going to be
your franchise quarterback you have to
figure out what's best for him
and if it's best that he hold the
clipboard for five or six weeks and then
he come in at some point during the
season that's what you do I mean the guy
who I would who I'd be really wondering
about right now is Daniel Jones because
he had such an excellent preseason and
not just as a caretaker rich he's had a
good pre-season throwing the ball
downfield as well he sure has asked the
poll question I got Ryan before Ryan
Leaf by the way he's Judy he's about to
come out here in person right here on
the riches Joe asked the question of
Peter the poll question Chris real quick
yeah beater who do you think wins AFC
South Indianapolis I think they've got
the best all-around team and I if I
trusted Houston's offensive line I'd
pick Houston but I think Indianapolis
still has the best all-around team
because I just think Houston's offensive
line is really gonna be a problem right
I hear you and then I'm also thinking
maybe Saint Nick Foles is the real deal
and Jacksonville gets healthy I mean it
you know the most fascinating it's the
most fascinating division in football I
mean what they you know the Titans won
what nine games last year and we're all
talking about them like we're throwing
them out with the trash and they're
they've got a really good defense Mike
rables a smart guy
you know I don't know but I would still
take Indianapolis right now Peter thanks
for the call
appreciate it we'll chat soon all the
best three right back at you at Peter
underscore King for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app